Pepper plants are popular at the Museo de
Ciencias Naturales in Madrid, Spain—
a country famous for using peppers in cuisine.
Yet it’s their roots, rather than their
succulent fruits,
that were the subject of new research
conducted at the museum’s greenhouse.
Though a plant’s growth above ground is
highly observable
its subterranean development lacks visibility.
This forces scientists to rely on piecemeal
techniques to measure roots’ spatial behavior—
or growth patterns according to distance—
and limited mathematical models to predict their biomass.
The recent research in Madrid sought to reconcile this dilemma.
A new mathematical formula incorporated both
space and biomass
to build a more complete model of root growth.
Researchers then tested its accuracy using
a novel experiment:
First, they set up soil-filled construction
gutters inside a greenhouse.
In some of the gutters, they arranged pairs
of pepper plants roughly 10 centimeters apart.
In others, solitary plants were grown without
neighbors.
All of the plants were given equal access
to light and water,
as well as fertilizer rich with phosphorous,
nitrogen, iron, and other key nutrients.
As the plants grew, scientists injected the
plant stems with red and blue dyes
so that they could distinguish between the
roots of competing plants.
Finally, they pieced together root fragments
according to their owners,
measuring their density, lengths, and positions
in the soil beds.
Plants tend to invest resources closer to
their stems,
adding more roots to the soil near their source
as they spread symmetrically.
But the experiment showed paired plants
invested even more resources closer to their stems than solitary plants.
They also grew fewer roots as they neared
their neighbors,
where resources became scarcer amid greater
competition.
These patterns closely aligned with the study’s
model,
which predicted that neighboring plant roots
would segregate and change how they invest resources
in order to acquire as many resources as possible.
By confirming the model,
the research helped resolve contradictory results from previous experiments,
where root biomass sometimes increased and other times decreased
in the presence of neighboring plants.
Turns out,
the closer the plants are to their neighbors,
the more they invest in their roots overall.
Their evolutionary programming causes them
to add more and more roots near their stems
rather than extend across space to compete
for survival.
The researchers believe their findings
could help genetically reprogram plants
to maximize crop yields.
Climate modelers could also make better projections of Earth’s vegetation—
a significant carbon sink—
by factoring in the underground life of plants.
Oh, the places they’ll grow…
[Music]